you brett wanted to start this week by
talking about why everything is labeled
in the inverse yes and uh i should say
we didn't mention at the top um there
are a couple of podcasts that i did in
bath that are out now and actually they
fit perfectly this topic so robert
malone uh sat with me you can find that
one on spotify that's not on youtube
because youtube can't handle the truth
youtube cannot handle the truth and
they're uh
their
community guidelines folks believe you
can't handle the truth um
garrett vandenbosch that one is out as
of two days ago um that one is out on
youtube and spotify i believe
that one is already out it is already
out and yes um both of these are and of
course neil oliver was the first one
that you did in england and there's two
more coming right there's two more
coming and then there was another one
that i recorded this week uh on a
slightly different topic
but in any case um all of these are
cases
in which we are wrestling with the
question of what the truth is and what
it isn't and many of us have noticed
that the labels on these things seem to
be flipped at an incredible rate in
modern times it's not like most of what
is uh discussed by official sources is
right and then every so often there's
something over which we disagree and
some thing that has been labeled wrong
turns out to be right if you look at
topics like
the covid pandemic
and
the public health reaction to it you
will find the labels are just simply
reversed right and that is uh
a conspicuous pattern because if we were
just simply confused you wouldn't expect
the labels to reverse you would expect
it to be noisy and contentious and you'd
get a hodgepodge so um examples of
labels here that you're thinking of well
uh let's just say if you were trying to
navigate what to do for your family in
light of
covet right let's say like us you
believe covet to be a dangerous and
destructive
pathogen and you're concerned about
preventing it and you're concerned
about
preventing transmission and you're
concerned about reducing the hazard that
the pathogen
poses to you and your family
well the question is if you go to the
cdc or the fda or the who or any of the
official sources if you go to the new
york times the washington post
you'll find the the answer is very clear
that these uh
vaccines which is the wrong term and
increasingly
people have begun to understand why this
is this is a matter of significance you
might say that they are transfective
agents um they are certainly
inoculations um but vaccine is not a
good definition for them but nonetheless
it's not the right it's not the word
that should be applied to them but
absent that word being applied to them
it would have been much harder to get so
many people on board right that's that's
just the thing so labeling them uh as
vaccines is a case in which you've got
um
the standard outlets all describing
these things in terms that are
inaccurate
the
value of these things was inaccurately
described from the beginning of their
efficacy if we're talking about in the
trial phase or their effectiveness once
they are released at preventing you from
contracting the disease preventing you
from transmitting the disease is
actually extremely low
but we are told that we must take them
in order to prevent the spread of this
dangerous disease that's
misinformation masquerading as
information
whereas we are told that repurposed
drugs um i won't mention the names so we
can leave them here on youtube but you
are free to infer that i am talking
about the same compounds that we have
been arguing about for many many months
older paste
walls of paste
um i think you should get the human
version but nonetheless there are
multiple repurposed drugs
that
uh clearly have high efficacy not only
have they been successfully incorporated
by the doctors who have been most
effective at treating patients
uh with covid they've been deployed
successfully around the world have
are clearly implicated in the crash of
waves of
covid that took place in places like
uttar pradesh
this is a good crash we're talking about
right so in any case what you've got
is actually effective
pharmaceuticals that we are told are
snake oil and we have something that
isn't a vaccine which we are told is a
vaccine that doesn't do the two most
important things that it would need to
do in order to control the pandemic and
to explain why they would be mandated
which is to prevent you from contracting
the disease and prevent you from passing
it on
um in other words what you've got is the
exact inverse of a recipe for protecting
yourself right you could have done the
right thing for your family if only you
had known that you should tune out the
new york times the washington post uh
the cdc the fda the who
um all the major universities right and
so this is a problem because for most of
us we are not equipped
to look at the entire range of
institutions and say they've all got it
wrong i mean even my voicing that sounds
perfectly insane what are the chances
that all the institutions got it wrong
and if they did all get it wrong
my point is we have to now go backwards
and say well
what could possibly explain that
yeah
one of the issues and uh
i i
i don't think i'm gonna step on any of
the toes that you were about to put into
the argument that didn't work at all
today
is
that when it's all the institutions
uh it raises the question of how is that
possible it could be all of them
and most people will look at that and
say well it's just so obvious it's just
so obvious that they have all come to
that and back in their mind whether or
not they are conscious of this maybe
whether or not people are actually
statistically sophisticated enough to
recognize that what they are imagining
is everyone came to this idea
independently right
whereas if it's really all the
institutions there's
there's now a reasonable chance that
actually that's a bunch of
non-independent data points
and that and you know we know that you
know the media aren't doing original
science that they have to accept the
authority from someone largely even
so-called science journalists largely
are not doing as much of the sort of
assessment of the signs that they're
reporting on as they should be
but at the point that there is
uniformity of agreement across all of
the domains
then you really do have to wonder about
whether or not the independence of the
data points and therefore the
independence of the press and academia
and everything is in fact present where
it it needs to be
right and
you know it should also be obvious to
people as they look at
the
supposed consensus in front of them that
those who have departed from the
consensus have had terrible things
happen to them right we all of us who
have departed from the consensus who are
professionally trained in any regard
have been dismissed as cranks and kooks
and worse we've been called grifters and
all sorts of things and so the point is
look you know there is an incentive to
stick with the conventional narrative
and then the consensus is uh trotted out
as evidence that uh the the the pattern
is very clear and anybody who you know
knows how to do the analysis will reach
the same conclusion that the cdc and the
fda and the who and the new york times
and everybody else has reached right
but the point is
when you see an intense campaign that
punishes people for stepping out of line
then you have to ask the question
what you know
how
how durable how meaningful is that a
potemkin consensus right is that a
paper-thin consensus born of the fact
that all of those who are capable of
seeing the problem with it are afraid to
say what they can see
[Music]
you